[Music]
in general humans primarily function off
of self-interest this sounds like a sad
thought to bear that even in the purest
appearing of people self-interest can
still remain but perhaps it's not
entirely a bad thing
perhaps we can use selfishness to
achieve selflessness on Commercial
Airplanes
in the case of an oxygen shortage adults
are instructed to put oxygen masks on
themselves before they assist children
or other incapable passengers arguably
this could be considered selfish
but its purpose is self less it is
logical an individual cannot help anyone
breathe if they are unable to breathe
themselves likewise one cannot give
something to the world if they do not
have it themselves
an unhappy person cannot help the world
be happy and a person without love
cannot give the world love in life a
person must first work to satisfy their
own needs even if they may initially
appear selfish needs like survival self
love self awareness self fulfillment and
so on if our selfish acts are calculated
and purposeful towards providing us with
the capacity to carry out the needs of
others we move through selfishness and
into selflessness the problem with this
process is how easy it is to become
swept away by our self-interest and
forget about the purpose of using it to
achieve selflessness we are seductive to
ourselves and easily become addicted to
creating a world around our ego we must
resist though and maintain a balance
between our self and the rest of the
world
well-being is rooted in altruism
it cannot nearly be self oriented just
like a financial investor invests the
portion of their money into a business
you must invest portions of yourself
into others and trust that your quality
of life will accrue in value when it
does you will i rana CLE end up with
what your selfishness wanted the whole
time a better life but at least in this
case you will have positively affected
others along the way and will have
shared in a collective happiness that is
enduring and wondrous
[Music]
you